[Music]
what's up you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey's back [ __ ] the head was a
little [ __ ] up but what are you gonna
do and I'm saying it's the Lord's Day
free I'm just warming up for the fight
tonight
I just had a couple [ __ ] tacos and a
little salad and now I'm ready to watch
the [ __ ] fights but you gotta get
fired up and stoned to the gills I still
haven't called in my little lineup yet
I like one big and one small and I'm
saying I'm in between them but who gives
a Flint Frenchman's [ __ ] what I think
opinions predictions they're all four
[ __ ] nothing really at mister you
lay down the key this I'm saying nothing
happens to you lay down the [ __ ]
deenis so talk to your nearest Jew make
the call do what you need to [ __ ] do
I don't want to hear I like this guy
like that nothing happens to you later
on the [ __ ] gave us now enough with
the [ __ ] didn't preaching here it's time
to smoke this [ __ ] death I got here
Iranian from Paris blah where the [ __ ]
perennial og from perennial and the
[ __ ] ghost just give that
[ __ ] I shot again I was stoned
till he kills before least I had came
over we had a few stars
I'm pumped up got something
I love [ __ ] marijuana I love it
medical explosive whatever the [ __ ] you
want to use it for I don't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] at this point Obama
catches his daughter smoking pot he goes
bananas where'd you get it at some
[ __ ] store on the corner they call
the DEA and now we got it [ __ ] come
down because Obama ain't got no [ __ ]
parenting skills James and you see how
life works out [ __ ] it's the
same beliefs that smoking dope you dirty
[ __ ]
no he calls the DEA like a crime stopper
that is yeah you gotta put this [ __ ]
together people they think I still
around smoking dope just sitting there
we're gonna trees I'm [ __ ] thinking
I'm going beep [ __ ] philosophizing
you know I'm saying
title is the reef they killed Prince
it's time for the ghost boo [ __ ]
Halloween Halloween
I'm down with ghosts year-round and the
stems you know why cuz that's how I roll
[ __ ] I'm not gonna get yelling
periscope and trying to tell him you're
[ __ ] adopted uncle if I'm not smoking
the death of debt I'm just [ __ ] with
you
we'll fill this one up to the [ __ ]
brim understand you know how we do it
you know are we doing dunk oh come on
here if you're under 18 hang up now
[ __ ] I don't want no [ __ ]
email from your mom tell me you're on
the boat from the [ __ ] balcony
periscoping your [ __ ] sister a
teacher trying to get your dick slip I
ain't mad at you I just don't need those
type of emails you know Sam oh I'm gonna
get [ __ ] up you know what at this
point in my life who gives a [ __ ] you
know what for the grave one up and have
a feel it's time to sling dick and [ __ ]
the regrets you follow me and if I'm
doing that my age what should you be
doing at 25 forget about I was 25 my
back right now the [ __ ] white horse
throwing spears at [ __ ] in stem
giving our [ __ ] yum Yum's spraying
[ __ ] tropical homemade juice on
[ __ ] you know make them
oh it's tremendous I feel it going into
my [ __ ] brain cavities you know I
have no [ __ ] brain I'm a half a week
done my grandmother and grandfather
behalf of cousins but it's an island
Willie expect anything new they didn't
read the travel brochure you know Sam
when you're on island you're gonna [ __ ]
it you gotta [ __ ] your cousin or
somebody eventually you know that's just
the way it is
oh I love the people I don't give a [ __ ]
you want to judge me judge me what do I
give a [ __ ]
I wrote a thousand letters to the judge
is where I am okay but that's it we're
gonna join now I checked in with your
mother [ __ ] later to make sure you
know everything's all right nobody's
[ __ ] foaming from the mouth my
borrowed him in lviv who [ __ ]
chocolate chip cookies that nasty
[ __ ] even hookers falling from
the [ __ ] are you kidding me
long so [ __ ] tremendous but the
digital delay got beat up and I will
give a [ __ ] yes but I'm going back
tomorrow the Lord's Day you know why cuz
we don't give a [ __ ] jack
all right I'll see you guys mid-fight
don't go nowhere [ __ ] we're going
deep to that I got a nice different
waifus I got the one I drew Canole with
so [ __ ] don't worry but nothing I'll
see you guys a little walk